اهلا بكم الى موجز لاهم الانباء قال جهاز
الامن الفيدرالي الروسي انه احبط هجوما
ارهابيا على المنشات النوويه الروسيه
واوضح ان من وصفهم بالمخربين الاوكرانيين
حاولوا تفجير نحو 30 خط كهرباء لمحطات
الطاقه النوويه عشيه عيد النصر وكانت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت ان السفينه
الحربيه ايفانورس تعرضت لهجوم فاشل من قبل
ثلاثه زوارقه اوكرانيه مسيره في البحر
الاسود عند اقترابها من مضيق البوسفور
افادت الاداره العسكريه في خملنسكي غربي
اوكرانيا بان انفجارات دوت في المدينه
بالتزامن مع تصدي الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه لمسيارات المفخخه كما تحدثت
سلطات اوديسا عن التعرض لهجوم ارهابي لمس
سيارات روسيه هجوميه واشارت الاداره
العسكريه في كييف الا ان الدفاعات الجويه
تتعامل مع هجمه معاديه بطائرات مسيره
واتهمت الاداره العسكريه في خاركيف القوات
الروسيه بقصف المدينه
اعلن حاكم مدينه سباستوبول الموالي لروسيا
عن احباط هجوم اوكرانيا بطائره مسيره
الليله الماضيه واضاف رز جايف ان الجيش
الروسيه صدى هجوما اخر بطائره مسيره اخرى
على
واسقط طائرتين من دون طيار
قال الناطق باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
مسيره تابعه للجيش تعرضت لاطلاق نار من
اسلحه خفيفه من داخل الاراضي السوريه
عندما كانت في مهمه جمع معلومات اعتياديه
وان قوات الجيش ردت باطلاق نيران اسلحه
رشاشه نحو المنطقه التي رصد منها اطلاق
النار
وقد اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي انه سيبدا
الاسبوع المقبل مناورات عسكريه شامله
تحاكي حربا على جبهات عده بما فيها جبهه
سوريا ولبنان
نقل موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤولون اسرائيليين
وامريكيين قولهم انه من المتوقع ان يصل كل
من مستشار الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ووزير
الشؤون الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه الى
واشنطن الاسبوع المقبل لاجراء محادثات
بشان البرنامج النووي الايراني
في المقابل قال رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه محمد اسلامي ان اسرائيل تحاول
تشديد الضغط على ايران عبر شني حرب نفسيه
عليها وطرح ادعاءات باطله منذ سنوات
كشفت وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه عن صاروخ
باليسي جديد يحمل اسم خيبر وهو نسخه معدله
من الصاروخ خرم الشهر وصنفته بالجيل
الرابع من هذا الطراز ويبلغ مدى الصاروخ
2000 كيلومتر ويحمل راسا حربيا يبلغ وزنه
1000 كيلوغرام
هذا المجلس شكرا لكم والى اللقاء